what is circumference
let's see let's take a circle with
radius r
a circle is basically a shape having all
its points equation from its center the
circumference is basically the total
length of its boundary
so this boundary length is called the
circumference
how is this measured well the formula of
circumference is 2 pi r
r is the radius of the circle and this
symbol here represents pi
but how did we arrive at this formula
and what is pi
what is its value and how can we really
understand it
let's see now you can take three circles
with diameter six seven and eight
centimeters
then with the string you can find out
the circumference of each circle
in the first case you will get the
answer as 18.85 in the second case
you'll get 22 and in the third case
you'll get 25.1
now why are we doing this
in all the cases when you divide the
circumference by the respective diameter
you will get the approximate answer as
3.14
and this constant is called pi
whenever you consider any circle the
value of circumference over diameter
will always be pi
and that is your constant
and we know that the diameter is twice
the length of the radius and we get the
formula of circumference as 2 pi r
but where did the symbol of pi come from
let us see that in our next video for
more such interesting math concepts
please subscribe to our youtube channel